Welcome everybody. This is Jason Rosen with US enzymes with Dr. Kevin Connors
To chat about a product that we actually developed together for
Well, we wanted to make something that was more than just a you know a typical gut healing product that covered a lot of bases
But had really really high quality well researched ingredients in it that you know had to have
had to not contain
Glutamine in it. I know that's a big big deal
Especially in the world that you deal with Dr. Connors. I know you were mostly supporting patients that have had had cancer
So why don't
Yeah, I hand it over to you a little bit and maybe you can give a little bit of a background again on what went into us
And then we'll get into the ingredients one by one and cover some of the different aspects research genetics things like that
Sure, so I mean it's obvious to most people in the that have issues
Physically that your health starts in the gut
Most lay people do any research
on
Any type of health, whether it's fatigue or thyroid issues or early dementia
Everything points back to working out a healing that got first
The struggle with it is that most gut healing products contained a lot of the amino acid L glutamine
Which one of the reason why it does is because L glutamine strongly stimulates a pathway called mTOR
And that's how it heals the mTOR pathway is what up regulates
Healing in growth
Which you think well that's important. We want to heal the gut and grow new cells and
Allow the epithelial lining of the gut to be healed and and
Algorithmic can be very efficient for that the problem comes in as if you have any history of cancer in your family
A history of cancer for yourself. You don't want to be up-regulated mTOR so there are other ways to heal tissue without up-regulated mTOR
When Jason and you and I were discussing this a number of years ago it's like we there's no products on the market though for this so you know you said well let's make one and I said okay let's do it. It took a while right well because a quality product isn't it's no picnic that's for sure
Well, it isn't and you know we went through a company that was completely crazy anal about
Perfection of ingredients and and there's times that you know from a clinical standpoint I
You know was it's you know you get a little upset because it's not happening as quickly as possible but from
From a personal standpoint it's the right thing to do because we wanted to come up with a product that was correct
Perfect
Requirements and worked and you know you were instrumental in that it's overseed that process and it's been phenomenal. Yeah, I know I really appreciate that and for me you know even you know
Being a pure annoyed myself with products. It just was like another
You know reassurance of big how important it is to just say pure annoyed
Yeah, pure annoyed
Yes, that
It is a minefield out there and any Joe Schmoh could just go to any contract manufacturer and just have a product whipped together and like next to no time but I'm telling you that
That the odds of that being a clean product your are slim to none so it is a minefield out there with cross contamination and you know
Assays so I would say a word to the wise you know ask your nutrition company to supply you an assay of your your product from the third party and if there hasn't had to do that then you know maybe a word of caution there so
Before
The the glutamine subject a couple other things to with glutamine we know now that it can deplete magnesium which you know is in short supply and in most people and it could be your potential like a neural your transmitter issue
As well so you would
Go ahead sorry
Glutamine is from the New York so let's say you got a doctor listening to this and say well I don't treat cancer patients said so that's not really an issue for me but if you have anybody with any early Alzheimer's any emotional issues any any spectrum patients
Asperger's
Autism you have to be very careful with glutamine as well because there's some specific genes that convert glutamine
To glutamate which glutamate is a excitatory door transfer how many people are walking around today with anxiety yep so anxiety stems completely from
Increased glutamates in the brain and many of them are because of genetic defects that up regulate the conversion of glutamine to glutamate
Which leads to all those conditions so
Even if you're not treating cancer patients you still have to be very careful with glutamine because
If you add together anxiety patients any emotional patients any depression patients any autism spectrum patients no matter where they are in the spectrum
To any possible cancer patients you've you've
Included now probably 90% of society right so I use it a glutamate product you could be contributing to ill effects of that person down the road and
You need to be responsible for that so true yeah, I mean
More and more doctors they they really need to take their time and do their studying. I mean a lot of people just
Want all in one like protocol or something and you know it just doesn't exist unfortunately people are different
They're getting this information so yes so true and for anyone listening and you know
Maybe while these guys especially Dr. Conner's knows a lot about the gut we did a couple other
Practitioner series called gut 101 and gut 102 where we really get into the gut at a much deeper level
You want to pop and look at those on our YouTube channels those would be a great place to start to for learning more about the gut
Okay, so now let's get to the ingredients that are in this guy and
The number one here is the sun fiber and like you'd mentioned there are other things that heal the gut and not only are there other things that heal the gut
This one is like at the top of the list as far as you know being researched to prove
That that can happen and as far as I know we're one of few companies that can even have a claim on the label that says digestive repair
And that's due to the research of this wonderful product called sun fiber so maybe Dr. Conner's you can talk a little bit more about the sun fiber and how this guy works with them you know butarate and things like that.
Well, it's essential to I mean that is your main fuel of the gut is butaric acid and that's what is formed with the sun fiber.
So again you're feeding the cells so that they can that they can reproduce and and heal without up regulating that and tore pathway.
So this is what we chose to be that go between so wouldn't stimulate any kids or growth it wouldn't stimulate any increased glutamates in the brain, but it would be a great source of healing for the gut and as far as I know it's probably the only gut product that that carries this.
There's other fiber products out there, but this is really meant to heal the gut when you combine it synergistically with the other ingredients in this.
Yeah, absolutely this is not just a typical fiber it is you know it's it's been hydrolyzed in a way that it's truly modular so it's you're like oh if I if I got diarrhea the last thing I want to do is take fiber well that's actually the opposite here.
This is a let's take an adapted genetic for your gut so all types of IBS this can be recommended and it is even recommended through you know medical doctors in Canada for all types of IBS which is it's rare it's one of the few things that they can actually recommend.
And as far as a supplement for people and suffering from all types of IBS so.
Another beautiful thing about it is it's probably the easiest nutritional product in the world that takes on fire because it is completely tasteless colorless and odorless if you can drink a glass of water you're fine.
And some of the other ingredients that we've added to this are very similar in the way that they're you know they don't really taste like anything so you mix this into a smoothie there's no way the patients can have.
You know really any idea that they're taking the supplement right.
All right so let's move on to the next ingredient so the sun fiber here this is for you know motility and for healing your gut and then the next player which is.
A huge thing in nutrition today is Kirkman but not only just traditional Kirkman this is a branded form meaning a consistent research patented form called C3 reduct which is just an absolutely fantastic product in that it covers a lot of the concerns with Kirkman being you know how am I going to be able to absorb it and how long is the half life.
So this is a Kirkman that's got a you know a bio availability three to four times greater than traditional Kirkman and it has a half life three to four times longer than traditional Kirkman and it's white it's water soluble so anyone that's taken Kirkman before you'll probably have.
They'll have complaints or the patients will complain about oh it stains it it smells it tastes bad well this form of Kirkman you don't have any of those concerns and you know Dr Conner's want to maybe get a little bit more into the massive benefits of Kirkman and you know why.
Definitely we could talk about that it's true Kirkman is a major player for slow eat him tour for increasing autophagy for decreasing in a cap of beta so it's it's a great player for cancer patients it's phenomenal to decrease overall inflammation of the body which you could argue that inflammation of the body is really.
At the base of just about every disease process yes and the beauty of this product is that the nearly one gram per serving is equivalent to three to four grams of other forms of Kirkman that someone else may be taking through another product so because of the bio availability of the tetrahider or crumid ones that are in this it's it's equivalent to three to four times in another product.
So you know again I was just sourcing this was difficult but it was worth the weight at getting this.
Yes yeah I totally agree and like you said we could just go on and on about Kirkman and like you said you know if you're treating cancer patients you know you treat just about any other patient I would say in a similar fashion especially for people working with auto immunity.
You know the similarities I would after talking to you are pretty astound and yeah we should mention that this product every ingredient and it is neutral the TH1 and the TH2 for any FM doctors you're working with a lot of auto immune type patients.
Yeah right so the next player is a q 10 that is a bio identical q 10 so again very important for being able to be absorbed so not only huge for cellular energy but you know critical for you know liver function so I know that was one of the big reasons we wanted you know this guy to get in here and it's also huge for you know gut function as well when you read books like brain maker.
You know by doctor pearl mutter he'll just talk all day long about uteric acid prebiotics in cellular energy and so that's definitely it what you know his influence went into this product as well from this reading you know his research and things like that so you know maybe Dr. Conner's can talk a little bit more about you know some of the reasons we use this and you know especially for liver function with people on all these methods.
This is key for detoxification I mean yeah you could say okay if anybody's on a lipitor type product then they're already diminishing their coq 10 but besides that coq 10 is so important for helping the side of the chrome p450 detox pathway the pump one pathway in a tea pathways it's just critical and you see that with with toxin burden that we live in.
With the viral toxic part that we have well we need support of those pathways so an essential nutrient that most people are very beneficial to add.
Yep we agree and again we source this from a highly reputable source and you know through obtained through fermentation which is just a lovely way to get a really clean clean nutrient.
Okay so the last thing we put in here is we know we want to put some type of probiotic into this product but we want to make sure we found something that was.
Really well researched and that we knew was researched for you know two of the biggest things that are critical when it comes to probiotics they're going to survive the acid of the stomach and that they're going to survive.
So we want to take a little bit of bio and be able to adhere to the intestinal lining so yeah doctor kind of wants to take away on a branded probiotic.
And that's the key I mean everybody's like okay I want to heal the guy in the first thing that many people go to is we're going to take a probiotic and many of the probiotics that you'll get over the color are getting survived the stomach acid so you're not getting a great benefit from it.
The key to the probiotic that we put in here like you mentioned is the survivability across the stomach but also it's just the synergistic relationship with the other nutrients in here if you're not healing the gut for it like I tell patients.
The prebiotic and the the curcumin in the cocutin are giving are basically helping build the apartment building so the probiotic have a place to live when they get there.
It's easy to understand that way so in creating this product overall okay we know what the gut needs to heal we got to add that all together so it's together in one product not only easier for the patient to take so they're not taking five different things.
But it they work together and it's that synergy working together that makes it really more than the sum of its parts and you know that's what we put our heads together to come up with this that was the key and like I've told you I literally put I think every person on some spectrum.
It is it is that important I take it every day it's it's it's just a product that covers so many bases and one could argue again that the gut is the is the source or at least a key component of just about every disease that exists.
So if you're not addressing that constantly because you know our environment is addressing it negatively constantly even if you're eating organic and try to do everything right.
You are exposed to GMO foods whether you are eating them or not yes and those are basically antibiotics and destroy your gut constantly not to mention you know everything else that.
Right supposed to yeah no great point it's a constant fight it's a constant fight it is it's a constant two and four.
But yeah no I just adore this product I take it I take a half scoop every morning with my juice and then in the evening I put a half a scoop in in my tea while I'm working and I think that's the way used to like like to use it with your patients a lot just like as a fusion drink or is that the way usually dose.
Yeah we usually dose in two doses per day yeah absolutely whatever it is whether I do a teaspoon of the morning teaspoon at night or you know double that or whatever we're doing it's we do two two doses a day so they're just having it constantly because everything that you eat has a half life all nutrients are going to have a half life in your body so you've got to kind of dose it across the day.
Yep completely agree with that and yeah this is something I give my son you know every single day it's just huge blessing to keep your children's got healthy I mean they come into this world with you know hopefully someone healthy got.
It's a really good way to maintain that given the things that they're exposed to and the stress is a school and then who knows what the situation is with the food that they might be almost forced to eat in school they're definitely gonna need.
Some help that's right yeah but you mentioned something as well like this is like a four and one you know product working all synergistically together so you know as far as the value for the price of this product I mean I just don't think you could get a better value if you went and bought these four supplements out on their own and had to take them to get you know enough to get a therapeutic amount of each you be spending.
Two to three times the cost of just the single product which has also been designed to last an entire month.
All right it's just the ease of patience. Yeah take it and make sure it's the swallow and yes.
All right anything else you'd like to add before we wrap up.
I don't have people feel free to contact me if they have any questions. I know that you're always open to that as well.
Yes appreciate that. Yep right here to get a hold of either of us we both have great YouTube channels where we've done videos together videos separately and we both just absolutely would say take a look at Conner's Facebook and YouTube page as well as USN Zimes.
So for Dr. Conner's Jason Rosen thank you once again for joining us and we hope to see you next time.
Bye bye.